[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis weiß
rheine gibt es ein leckeres bisher ich
mache verweile kummer und zwar sind das
kleine pudding röllchen mit schokolade
das ganze ist natürlich sehr und es
passt richtig gut zur ramadan zeit weil
es einfach super leicht ist in der
herstellung auch ganz einfach ist und
nicht so schwer im magen liegt ich zeige
euch mal die zutaten für den pudding für
den pudding verwende ich einen liter
milch 200 gramm zucker 150 gramm mehl 50
gramm kakaopulver etwas vanille extrakt
und zum dritten welt sind kokosflocken
das bisher ist wirklich super einfach
ihr nehmt jetzt einfach ein bisschen
milch in den topf daraus wird jetzt ein
putting hergestellt dann zucker rein
ihr könnt doch gern etwas weniger oder
mehr nehmen dann das mehl in der türkei
bindet man und diesen putting nämlich
gerne mit mehl also einmal liebe heißt
es dort
putting ist da er so ein neuer begriff
war zu früher hat man echt immer nur
halb nackt und putin kam dann glaube ich
so ein bisschen international jetzt hier
also kakaopulver schön einrühren oder
daneben hören
nicht nehmen menschen einfach noch mit
einem milch aufgießen und schön
verrühren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
natürlich klappt das nicht verlängern
deswegen habe ich in eine mauer lassen
die staubsauger gemacht jetzt bring
geschmack etwas vanille extrakt könnt
ihr natürlich auch gerne mandl extrakt
einfügen oder orange das können die wege
ich den pudding oder das moral wir so
verfallen und wie ihr gerne möchte
grossenbacher wird auch gehen oder auch
auf dem dritten woche dann ist das
orientalische und jetzt in pudding weil
mittel hoher hitze während im rühren
aufkochen lassen und so etwa drei bis
vier minuten köcheln lassen
aber immer schön rief damit nichts
anbrennt am anfang denkt man immer tut
nix aber dann kommt der punkt dann merkt
man jetzt mit der pudding fest also
wirklich nicht so hoch gehen mit der
temperatur sonst rennen durch echter
boden an bisschen köcheln lassen aber
wie gesagt ganz vorsichtig
jetzt habe ich hier die kokosflocken auf
ein blech gestreut relativ gleichmäßig
dann nehme ich ein blech worin ich
später auch schneiden kann also das ist
ganz wichtig etwas zu offen welche
genommen das ist ja immer hier
da passiert nichts jetzt kommt hier der
wahre pudding drauf
[Musik]
jetzt vorsichtig mit einer palette oder
mit einem großen messer verstreichen
einfach schön glatt und so groß wie es
blech ungefähr vom rand bleibe ich ein
bisschen weg damit zusammen rat nicht an
gelebt also ein bisschen schwierig aber
es geht und die kokosflocken dienen
jetzt dazu dass der pudding und nicht
haften bleibt und nach dem abkühlen
kommt hier noch eine sandschicht rein
und dann kann ich schön aufrollen
vielleicht stellt sich einfach kurz zur
seite dann in den kühlschrank dann muss
es richtig kalt werden und dann wäre ich
schon gesagt für ihn abschlagen jetzt
ist der pudding abgekühlt jetzt mache
ich hier noch eine sahne creme dafür
gebe ich jetzt die saale in eine
schüssel dann nehme ich etwas
orangenaroma also orangen extrakt ist es
ganz natürlich ihr könnt natürlich auch
orangen abrieb mit rein geben aber so
habt ihr dann auch keine stückchen mit
dabei und erreichen wirklich 34 tropfen
sehr sehr sehr sehr intensiv und dann
nämlich noch seiner partnerstadt
schlagen zucker lasse ich jetzt weg
wollte den pudding einfach süß genug ist
[Musik]
die creme mit dem tier drauf gestrichen
dann gleichmäßig verstreichen
[Musik]
jetzt halte ich die platte längst
komplett drauf angebot jetzt machen
wollte und dann jetzt einfach die breite
zu schneiden
ich mache das ja zur etwa ist jeden
zentimeter breit zeig euch jetzt schon
mal bis erste aufgerollt wird und zwar
hier den anfang ganz vorsichtig anheben
und nach vorne rollen
[Musik]
so sieht es jetzt aus bis zum verzehr
werden sind natürlich kalt gestellt denn
dieser sache drin
damit sie auch schon die form behalten
und jetzt darf dem anprobieren und ich
glaube sehr mag hat das bestimmt noch
nie gegessen
ich habe eine kleine portion kann ja
nochmal nachlegen sagt bloß du warst
auch eine deftige die sprüh sagen ich
hab ja auch so weiß also nur sagen das
ist echt heftig
das mache ich es immer so wenn ich sowas
anne becher eis bekommt manchmal war da
unten rein banque syz & braucht weil
dann friert das so bisher
genau das so leicht oder löffel was für
marcel duchamp caroline schmeckt man die
orange rot ich habe interessante nämlich
orange okay dann vielleicht zwei drei
kilo mehr okay aber gut du würdest du
nachmachen
wo ist noch mal essen und mégane ist gar
nicht schwer zwar wirklich ein
superschnelles einfaches rezept man
braucht nur platz im kühlschrank für das
blech ansonsten passt alles litz rezept
falls ihr es nach machen wollt probiert
gerne aus ihr könnt das ganze soll
natürlich auch mit vanillepudding machen
und kakao weglassen dann solltet ihr
vielleicht sich die creme einfärben oder
eine schoko creme machen damit einfach
irgendwie doch im kontrast da ist oder
zum beispiel mit dem etwas sonderbar da
könnte eine erdbeer creme reinmachen
schokocreme das passt denke ich auch
ganzen variationen gibt es genug
ihr könnt sie gerne ausprobieren auf
sase - blog.de steht noch mal das rezept
und da gibt es übrigens auch die
kategorie ramazan rezepte
da könnt ihr gerne mal im archiv schauen
was ich die letzten jahre so alles
gemacht habe
also viel spaß beim nachmachen ich
wünsche euch eine schöne ramadan zeit
und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]